servus aus barcelona herzlich willkommen
zu nehmen ich bin also jetzt nicht mehr
besteht ja herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video in dem wir heute
herausfinden werden wer mich besser
kennt meine mutter oder meine schwester
ich habe zehn fragen vorbereitet lasse
die beiden gegeneinander antreten schaut
wer von den beiden mich besser kennt
oder melde wahlergebnis haben und wir
werden wissen werde das beste der
familie ist für mich also aber werden
wissen wenn ich am besten kenne ich und
wir legen jetzt los ok hinter der kamera
mit meiner schwester und hier in diesem
setting habe meine mutter hinter der
kamera und wir fangen jetzt direkt an
ich habe zehn fallen für dich
vorbereitet wann habe ich mein erstes
youtube video hochgeladen
[Musik]
also september 2015
ja gut für meine mutter denn es war
dezember 2013 also näher am september
was ist mein lieblingsessen die mit
[Musik]
christoph müller ja sogar die dinge so
ok ich gar nicht mehr weiß wenn man so
die dinge die so machen
du meinst amerikanische rapper oder
kleiner tintenfische richtige antwort
gewesen zu schieben ich wollte sich
gemeistert was ist mein tollstes paar
schuhe und wie viel kostet also einer
einzigen beiden sagen richtige antwort
wäre gewesen 400 euro dh nächste frage
wie groß bin ich genau
[Musik]
194 1 81 98 sportlich denn ich bin
eigentlich nur 191 groß heißt punkt für
meine mutter wie viel ps hatte mein
erstes auto kommt hintergründe
vermeintlich und am nächsten dran wieder
meine mutter werden das ding hat 109 ps
damals scheiße
foto 216 dann was meine lieblingsmusik
richtung doppelhaus ist ein drei
musikrichtungen insgesamt 30
das hören die auf der straße den ganzen
tag aus rap und ich schwöre dir kannst
du bitte auf wendet sich hier zu spielen
in der stadt allemal sparen wir herz
spielen die kommentare sind mehrere
techno classic eingetragen
da habt ihr beide 2 richtigen nämlich
rap und tekna bei dir im rathaus bei dir
natürlich nein nein meine lieblingsmusik
richtung sind hip hop techno und youtube
haus welches fortbewegungsmittel hasse
ich am meisten wahrscheinlich das
klavier von diesen sparen die also tun
ich liebe autofahrer veranlassen laufen
laufen vielleicht ja ok das würde jetzt
jetzt fortbewegungsmittel 10
wir sind ja schon mit verve an ich sage
fahrrad weil das falsch wichtiges zog
ich hasse zu bezahlen über alles aber
ich mag das einfach nicht so mit
üblichen wildfremden leuten so lange auf
einen innenraum ein gefecht seien die
deswegen kanton für die massen
ich merke ich das ist meiner schuhgröße
[Musik]
ja da wir gestern darüber geredet ja ja
ich weiß nicht 5 46 es richtig von
schwester die viele autounfälle hatte
ich bisher nein also wenn ich heute
vielleicht kraft und das schon ziemlich
hart schon immer da ja ich weiß du bist
einfach so komische kippen beschreibt
waren 443
beide gleich abstands richtige antwort
denn das waren genau zwei einmal bin ich
nachts an münchen vorbei gefahren dass
in dem ihr eingeschlafen und so sagt man
einmal jemand die vorfahrt genommen aber
bisher beide nicht verschuldet und zu
guter letzt wie ich meinen bürger beim
bürger wissen sie das essen sind es
trage ich mal so ein habe ich persönlich
jetzt noch nicht gehört dem ansprechen
wahrscheinlich und die falsche antwort
der skater war es wahrscheinlich trage
sei natürlich richtig punkte meine
schwester damit kommen wir falls nicht
komplett anders bitte mich verzählt habe
was nicht auszuschließen ist auch einen
endstand von 4 punkten
meine schwester und 7 punkten bei meiner
mutter ich hab die kalkulierte das
geschäft geworden du kannst dich ja
werden cloud und den sorgen die ich
geworden
leute wie immer hier könnte man klar
wohin ihr persönlich mit fotos video
abchecken und hier kommt ihr zur
neuesten verholfen was das geht zeigt
das update ist es